okay go ahead have your opinion what do
you why chocolate flavored things whoa
something about chocolate flavored like
chocolate ice cream chocolate biscuits
just makes me feel kind of sick
is this is this this is cool i can do
this again are you playing devil's ad
the kid or is this family
this is genuinely how i feel that's
there's no way you actually believe that
i believe that it's a [ __ ] copious
that's how it is when i taste chocolate
flavored things i'm like literally any
other flavor would be better than this
bro you advocate for vanilla i love
vanilla you advocate for vanilla
chocolate i'm shocked vanilla is an
amazing taste but i have a feeling
you've said an opinion about chocolate
where you were praising like chocolate
flavored things in a part
maybe i'm just tripping maybe our
audience will remember chocolate bars
like
milk chocolate dark chocolate bars i
[ __ ] love i think that they're
amazing but that's like the that's like
just the chocolate in its purest form
give me the [ __ ] cocoa bean bag and
to [ __ ] shove it in my mouth but
that's like
i don't really like chocolate cookies
fudge uh fudges okay chocolate cake
chocolate cake is too much
[Laughter]
i am trying to process i can i can hear
the blood boiling in i just think
there's too much chocolate like shoved
into like per bite but like you fudge is
like even more intense than chocolate
cake is and you're saying chocolate cake
some fudges are okay but
it's some
brownies brownies okay brownies are good
but brownies isn't like more heavy they
say but they [ __ ] up that's like
concentrated chocolate yeah but brownies
are like there's got to be warm brownies
as well i don't like cold brownies well
nobody likes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay there we go there we go i
don't know so just i don't know
brownie's uh again like and i can't i
i'm sure you're the same i i don't know
anyone anyone who could eat like a [ __ ]
ton of brownies like i can watch
that's the stone when you talk yeah
plain fresh cookies chocolate chip
perfect like that's that's perfection in
the cookie to me
right a chocolate cookie is too much
too much chocolate flavor
i'm not trying to say this i'm trying to
comprehend
this is not one of my opinions where i'm
like i believe that you both are wrong
and you should definitely 100 understand
my like i get it that oh don't worry
we're not this could definitely be the
weird opinion why is there so much dust
in front of me what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] happened i was just like sneezing
getting that old
just
i think i've like aged 50 years one
conversation going on just like 50 50
[ __ ] dust particles in my face yeah
so i think here uh there's dust in my
face
my oxygen has been compromised but it's
[ __ ] dust
um yeah no i i i just think vanilla is
an amazing flavor um of course you do
yeah it's just too sickly for me i i
know that that's not normal though i
know that's me yeah no okay look don't
get me wrong i understand the point of
too much chocolate it gets me sick right
because
but that's a lot of sweet things like
too much vanilla will make me sick as
well i will say one of my favorite
desserts is uh sticky toffee pudding
that's good though that's like more i
like it when you have the chocolate
stuff with like a big like a sauce or
something to help with the flavor like a
chocolate sauce for instance no no
chocolate sauce on chocolate is [ __ ]
disgusting that's way too much well that
that's that wouldn't that be like a
chocolate lava cake like you don't like
those no no actually they're okay it
depends
it's like a few bites like one or two
again it's a sickly thing it's not a
taste thing it's a sickly thing so are
you like this with any other sweet
things or is it just specifically
chocolate like sticky toffee pudding is
like way more sickly than anything
chocolate yeah that's why you have the
vanilla ice cream to neutralize it you
know what i mean yeah okay so are you
the same with vanilla ice cream for
instance like if you eat enough vanilla
ice cream will you get something like no
i can't i can go to town on vanilla ice
cream
i can i can what is that what was that
what was that what was that the [ __ ] was
that that was our same brain cells just
firing off
oh connor has an opinion again yeah it
is it is it's the slow headser and i'm
like excuse me i i i'm sure there are
some other people out there who think
that chocolate is too sickly
i agree with you
a lot of chocolate is very very heavy
this is the problem tastes right is that
i don't know if my opinion is a general
shed opinion and you two are just clowns
it's a bit of both i think we're all
clowns
you can't just dismiss every chocolate
item aside from chocolate bars that is a
clown i know i'm saying like a chocolate
uh what was the [ __ ] fountain
whatever you talking about
the lava cake whatever yeah lava
chocolate cake right great example one
bite god tier i love that [ __ ] it tastes
great two bites i'm like oh my god i
feel like i'm about to [ __ ] die
that's why literally you use the same
strat as you do with the sticky toffee
pudding you can never have a chocolate
lava cake by itself
like ice
i hate toffee for the same reason you
hate chocolate stuff because it's
particularly yeah it's way too sickly i
like i i don't like caramel stuff it's a
weird one because i know i i especially
on this chocolate thing i contradict
myself a lot yeah so it's very much dish
dependent i i get you on the fact that
like too much chocolate is sickly but
i'm like that with all sweet things not
just chocolate like if i eat enough
[ __ ] strawberry flavored ice cream or
like vanilla rice like for me i think
i'll get sick i think chocolate ice
cream has got to be like
bottom tier like [ __ ] f-tier it's
like one of the ones no strawberries
bought them too okay okay
do we agree boys
strawberries strawberry ice cream unless
they they use like god tear fresh
strawberries and it's made up yeah but
it's never i know it's nevertheless
like you could say that's the same thing
about any kind of like dessert right you
use the fresh ingredients yeah it's
gonna be better well then that's like
okay every like ice cream or dish or
milkshake or whatever it has that has
that the distinct like
uh cheap flavor that every like flavor
alternative has like banana has that
cheap flavor yeah yeah chocolate has
that cheap flavor go-to right strawberry
has that but so does vanilla uh yeah
yeah vanilla but i think out of all of
them like the cheap flavor like
strawberry is probably the worst one oh
yeah and then chocolate because i i
realized like two of my favorite fruits
are strawberry and banana right i
[ __ ] love eating those fruits
yeah absolutely
go to it but i hate anything that's
flavored like them you know i like
flavored things do you like banana ice
cream uh yeah yeah yeah i like bananas
but it's not my go-to it's it's it's
like my fourth choice listen if i'm
getting the banana i'm getting three
scoops someone is one of them like i
need something else to ride right right
because yeah dude i mean there's this
one there's an ice cream place in
hokkaido and so it's like a chain that
you only get in hokkaido dude they do
like the most insane flavors of ice
cream and it just makes ice cream like
another level it's like you just can't
go back to home but that's just hokkaido
just being but like it was like it was
like you'd get ice cream and it's like
tiramisu ice cream and i'm like i'm just
i'm just there for that like that's
i am there okay that is a game changer
and there was caramel macchiato ice
cream i what oh my god
privileges
if that's what it means to eat ice cream
like that i'm i'm on board then would
you ever order a sorbet for dessert oh
[ __ ] no sorbet is sorbet is dog [ __ ]
here of like i think the problem with
sorbet is that you can have really good
sorbets but at the same time you can
have some real dogs
sometimes
so bad
i'm like come here just tell me you
couldn't afford gelato or ice cream just
say it okay because like you've
literally complained about chocolate ice
cream being too heavy sometimes you have
a heavy meal you're like they bring out
the dessert
just come in just give me a just [ __ ]
come out with a tunes a teaspoon and
just pour the flavoring directly in my
mouth don't give it to me through this
icicle [ __ ] i don't want a [ __ ]
ice cone right it's not even an ice hole
it's like an ice that you literally just
caught a sorbet it's like a hard ice
cone bro it tastes like [ __ ] off
that is so casual
that you've said a lot of cat things
this episode that is the most
like dog [ __ ] dessert dude it's like it
is not bro it's so bad that's like if
you need if you need a light dessert if
if something creamy like ice cream cone
sometimes i have a meal so happy i don't
want to know it's not creamy enough it's
just that's the whole point of it
cream's heavy it's not meant to be a
heavy dessert it's like it's like
just admit it you're you're you're a
snow cone with like a droplet of cream
just get it out of the way sometimes you
need a dessert that's a different kind
of heaviness to ice cream sometimes i
don't want ice cream to finish yeah
sometimes i don't want ice cream and
sometimes i don't want fruit as a
dessert it's like sometimes i want it's
like it's like the sorbet the part i
probably strawberry mainly is okay one
the texture is awful i just don't like
it because i'm also i'm a i'm a snow
cone hater uh and and it's it leans too
closely to that kind of okay you don't
like you don't like cocky audience
it's awful oh my god um and
also my other problem with it is that
every sorbet flavor just seems to be
awful like they just they they can never
make it it's literally like fruit
flavored